the Joe Rogan experience how do you
navigate this Tulsi it seems like the it
seems like okay if you want to get the
Democratic nomination you've got to be
pretty far to the left right but if you
want to actually win the presidency then
you've got to be more moderate so that
seems like a tough little thing to try
and get through as well I think that
that is the conventional so-called
wisdom that just isn't true anymore I
think this is what you know you hear a
lot of the political pundits talking to
lose far left to centrist moderate who's
this this that I think what's what's
proving to be true is it's more about
you know who is who is who's the
establishment candidate versus who is
anti-establishment and that you know I I
don't fit into any one of those boxes
because I look at every issue based on
its merits I look at the substance of
the issue look at the arguments for and
against and go with the approach that I
think this is a radical idea that's the
thing like these people they're like oh
my god we can't figure her out cuz she
doesn't have any of these labels but but
that is where the vast majority the
american people are you have these these
extremes on the fringes who are all
about these you know purity tests where
you are either with me on every single
issue or you're done you're finished
you're unacceptable but the vast
majority of americans again they're
looking at what is real leadership real
leadership whether you're talking about
the guy who's working in the
manufacturing warehouse you're talking
about a blue-collar worker you're
looking at okay here's here's the here's
the issues that keep most people up at
night you know you want to make sure
that if your kid is sick that you're
gonna be there they're gonna be able to
get the health care they need you want
to make sure you have a roof over your
family's head they're there basic things
approaching them in a way that is
pragmatical pragmatic common sense and
solutions oriented is not only the right
thing to do i think it's the thing that
makes it so you don't have to say well
in the primary i'm only going to talk
democrats and the most radical nick and
extreme among them
and then I'm totally gonna flip the
script and then speak to the whole
country after I win the primary election
that's that's ridiculous
this is why you know I'll go on Fox News
MSNBC CNN and I'm delivering the exact
same message to people and we're
building and growing supporting people
who watched those three different
channels who were actually listening
like me like she makes sense like she's
not crazy she's not spouting some party
talking point she's not you know going
down a radical path just to appeal to
the the Twitter winds that are blowing
one way or the other it's just about hey
let's do what's what's best
let's do its best for the people and for
the country I'm stunned by the blow back
to for you going on Fox News the people
actually upset that they do not think
that you should grace this the the Fox
News screens yeah they you you're doing
a disservice to your party yeah
which is interesting well I get the same
stuff and because I go on Fox News and
why do I go on Fox News Fox News invites
me on the Fox News you know who's never
invited me on MSNBC and again as you
pointed out earlier like it's pretty
hard to pin me down politically right
yeah and I'm not one to sit there and
try and make radical statements to try
and get more you know likes on the
Twitter thing you don't do that okay
yeah I don't it's like oh I'm here
trying to make some points about the way
you know most of what I talk about is is
about leadership yeah it's like oh
because of what we're doing as human
beings is we're leading other people
whether it's just your family or whether
it's your business or whatever or its
troops out in the field so yeah it's
weird that you would get attacked for
going on Fox News when actually anybody
that looks at that from a strategic view
would think oh she's actually accepted
by by this this right-wing news
organization maybe she could get some
other you know moderate conservative
votes maybe we should think about
bringing her as a candidate because she
could win well not only that what's
wrong with going on stage or going on
camera with someone that you oppose
someone you disagree with and having a
dialogue about what you disagree with
right that's the weird thing about this
cancel culture this is strange time
we're living and you're not even
supposed to communicate with people
about ideas that you disagree on yeah
a guy sizing you but being on Tucker
Carlson John particularly yeah and
that's all gonna say you know yeah it's
one thing to say okay you're gonna go on
fox news and you know tussle with sean
hannity about things you disagree on but
I think what they see is more dangerous
is finding areas where you actually do
agree right and that's you know I on
Tucker Carlson I have a platform to be
able to speak to millions of people
across the country about the kind of
leadership that I bring in the area of
foreign policy what I would do here in
this country what I would do there in
that country if I were president today
and I have the opportunity to deliver
that message directly to people's living
rooms or offices or wherever they are
and you know I think in some of these
areas Tucker Tucker and I will disagree
on a whole host of things but on some of
these issues of foreign policy you'll
say yeah I I agree with you and I think
when you look at this this canceled
culture how you know I was attacked on
the debate stage for going on Fox News
how do you think you're gonna lead this
country all Americans if you're
completely not only shutting out and not
willing to talk to half the country that
watches Fox News but you're in fact
disrespecting and dismissing them just
because they may disagree with you or
they watch a different news channel than
you do I think that's the bigger issue
here is yeah you know there's a
political consequence you're never gonna
be able to have a dialogue with what to
speak of win support from people who you
treat like garbage who you disrespect
you call names who you call deplorable
but how do you expect to lead as the
president of every single American in
this country when you've thrown half of
them away and saying you know what I
actually don't care about you I only
care about people who I agree with
that's that's to me the the worst part
about all of this does uh that
deplorable thing it was a big hit and
then you also remember when Mitt Romney
said hey there's 47% of the country that
there's no way vote for him so we're
just need to forget about them yeah
exactly those two those two things
completely divided and
sent people to vote for the opposing
candidate like you didn't call me
deplorable oh really
watch this I'm voting for you're gonna
ignore me or you're just dismissing my
vote doesn't matter I think also it
speaks to what both people have that
it's distasteful that they're calculated
and one of the things that I do
appreciate you about you is that I think
you're not I think the way you view
things is you would far rather speak
your mind and be truthful and have real
legitimate opinions on things rather
than have some weird slimy sort of
shifty take that's been created by a
bunch of people that think that this is
going to be the right thing that you
could say that's gonna in you know and
get youse a little closer in the polls
and move you this way and move the
needle that way that that shifty style
of politics I really feel is dead I just
I just don't think you can do it that
way anymore I think people because of
the open access to information that
people have today in the the way that
people can communicate and and find out
information I just don't think we want
to buy that shifty politician talk
anymore I think we're done with it I
think we realize it's antiquated it's
it's never served us it sucks and it
just it just gives you the same thing
every time you get someone who gets into
office and they do the completely
different things and what they said they
were gonna do before they got in yeah
that's even you know I thought about all
the people are they hurt deplore polls
they hurt 47% and that's bad but yeah
you're right what it really made people
think is oh behind the scenes you're
totally different than you are when
you're standing on stage shifty I know
what you're liking I'm not voting for
you
[Applause]